vamos a practicar un poco estas
ecuaciones exponenciales y justo aquí
tengo una dice 26 elevado a la 9 x + 5
este es el exponente esto es igual a 1
entonces pausa el vídeo y pepsi puedes
decirme cuál será el valor de x
bueno la clave aquí es darnos cuenta que
26 elevado a la potencia 0 es igual a 1
porque recuerdan cualquier cosa elevada
a la potencia cero
es lo mismo que 1 así que déjame ponerlo
aquí 26
esto elevado a la potencia cero esto
elevado a la potencia cero va a ser
igual a uno estás de acuerdo porque
recuerda cualquier cosa elevado a la
cero es igual a uno bueno cualquier cosa
que no sea cero a la potencia cero tal
vez en otro momento vamos a discutir que
es cero elevado a cero pero por ahora no
cualquier otra cosa que no sea cero
elevado a la potencia cero nos tiene que
dar 1 y eso quiere decir que el 9 x + 5
eso tiene que ser igual a cero es más
déjame ponerlo aquí 9 x + 5 esto tiene
que ser igual a 0 y esto ya está muy
fácil de resolver losas de acuerdo
primero vamos a restar 5 de ambos lados
de esta ecuación me va a quedar que 9 x
es igual a menos 5 muy bien y después
dividimos todo entre 9 todo entre 9 así
estos dos se van a cancelar me va a
quedar que x
es igual a menos 5 novenos y ya está esa
es la solución de este primer problema
ahora qué te parece si bajó un poco la
pantalla y resolvemos un ejercicio más
vamos a bajar un poco la pantalla y
vamos a ver el siguiente ejercicio pero
ahora va a ser un ejercicio un poco más
interesante bien pensemos la siguiente
me voy a tomar se me ocurre 2 2 elevado
a la 3 x 5 a 3 x + 5 y esto lo voy a
hacer igual a 64 esto elevado a la x
menos 7 y una vez más pausa el vídeo ip
si puedes decirme cuál es el valor de x
cuánto debe de valer x para satisfacer
esta ecuación exponencial bien vamos a
trabajarlo juntos
tal vez lo primero que viste es que
estaba sentado a decidir qué bueno este
exponente de aquí 3 x 5 tendría que ser
igual a x 7 pero date cuenta que eso no
funcionaría porque tenemos bases
distintas tú tienes 2 elevado a la
potencia 3 x + 5 es igual a 64 elevado a
la potencia x menos 7 entonces la clave
aquí va a ser expresar a ambos lados de
la ecuación con la misma base pero por
suerte 64 es una potencia de 2 así que
veamos a 2 elevado al cubo 2 elevado al
cubo es 8 y 8 x 8 es 64 así que todos
elevado al cubo por 2 elevado al cubo es
lo mismo que bueno 2 elevado a la sexta
potencia que es lo mismo que 64
8 x 8 64 y lo puedes verificar si pones
al 2 multiplicándose por sí mismo 6
veces y vas a obtener 64 solo que esto
es un poco más fácil para mí 8 x 8 es lo
mismo que 2 elevado a la sexta potencia
que es 64 y bueno observa que como
tenemos la misma base
sabía que dar 2 a la sexta potencia
porque sume los exponentes y ya con esto
puedo poner al 64 como 2 elevado a la
sexta potencia es más déjeme escribirlo
en el lado izquierdo tengo 2 elevado a
la 3x más 5 esto va a ser igual a 64
pero en lugar de 64 voy a escribir bueno
2 elevado a la sexta potencia a 2
elevado a la sexta potencia esto a su
vez está elevado a la potencia x menos 7
así que tengan escribirlo a la potencia
x
-7 y para simplificar esto un poco más
solo tenemos que recordar que si elevó
algo a una potencia y luego lo elevó a
otra potencia esto es lo mismo que
elevar mi base al producto de las
potencias déjenme escribirlo por aquí si
tomo algo y lo elevó a una potencia y
después esto mismo lo elevó a otra
potencia esto va a ser igual a ese mismo
algo a la base elevado al producto de
las potencias al producto de las
potencias entonces en este caso voy a
multiplicar este 6 que tengo aquí tanto
por x como por este 7 que tengo aquí voy
a distribuir este 6 que multiplica a x
menos 7 y que me va a quedar bueno del
lado izquierdo sigo teniendo dos elevado
a la 3x
+ 5 mientras que del lado derecho voy a
tener 2 ^ que potencian bueno 6 por x es
6x y después 6 x menos 7 es menos 42 así
que voy a multiplicar las dos potencias
y me queda 6 que multiplican a x 7 muy
bien ahora observa que me quedé con algo
muy interesante tengo 2 elevado a la 3 x
5 esto tiene que ser igual a 2 elevado a
las 6 x menos 42 eso quiere decir que ya
tenemos la misma base y por lo tanto
estos tienen que ser los mismos
exponentes estos tienen que ser los
mismos exponentes eso quiere decir que
3x más 5 esto tiene que ser igual a 0
x menos 42 y resolvamos esto tenemos una
linda ecuación lineal y para resolver
esto qué te parece si dejamos todas las
x del lado derecho porque aquí tenemos
más x y para eso voy a restar 3 x de
ambos lados de esta ecuación de este
lado voy a restar 3x y desde el otro
lado también voy a restar 3 x muy bien y
si ahora quiero quitar este 42 de aquí
voy a sumar de ambos lados 42 voy a
sumar aquí 42 y aquí también voy a sumar
42 y que voy a obtener bueno observa que
estas tres x se cancelan estos dos 42 se
cancelan y me va a quedar que 542 es 47
esto va a ser igual a 6 x menos 3 x lo
cual es 3
de lujo y ahora observa que si solamente
divido entre 3 a ambos lados así voy a
obtener el valor de x así que estos dos
se van a ir y me va a quedar que x va a
ser igual a 47 47 sobre 3 y ya está ya
tengo el valor de x y por lo tanto lo
hemos logrado